lasse Mathe ist in hofft dass es hier im
Merlin später voll wird
anders als zuletzt in Leipzig da kamen
zu seinem Konzert nur 35 Leute
in zwei Leute davon gehen und was
besonders mir nach Hause nehmen dann war
das das künstlerisch Wert für mich
aber natürlich nicht besonders schön
finanziell zwar gehen Musikfans
widerspontan zu Konzerten
man ist Single man geht gerne raus man
erlebt ein bisschen was man lebt gern
vor allem nach den letzten Jahren doch
davon profitieren vor allem die großen
internationalen Bands wer sind denn die
Künstler die morgen irgendwie diese
große Arena erfüllen wenn die nicht in
diese ganze kleineren oder mittleren
das finde ich das sage ich ein Problem
nach Corona machen die steigenden Preise
Veranstaltern und klubbetreibern
drei Jahre ist der erste Corona schatter
und mittlerweile her damals gab es
Videos wie diese Musikerinnen und
Musiker die nicht wissen wie es
weitergeht keine Konzerte kein Theater
die Veranstalter riefen Alarmstufe Rot
aus es folgten Rettungspakete mit
Milliarden von Bund und Ländern
und heute
hier als Branche nicht mehr auf der
Intensivstation sind sondern uns jetzt
in der Reha befinden heißt aber auch das
ganze Thema ist nicht vorbei wie lange
kann die Branche noch so durchhalten und
wie blickt sie auf 20 23
Klasse mathesen ist in die Musiker lebt
in Berlin und Kopenhagen die Pandemie
hat seine Karriere einen Dämpfer
verpasst die Tour zum Album musste er
mehrfach verschieben zwar findet sie
Ende 2022 endlich statt wie vorher ist
es aber nicht
anders als bei den großen Bands sie
liefern ihren Fans Shows in vollen
Hallen als wäre nichts gewesen
internationale Konzertveranstalter
melden Rekord Umsätze ob es bei lass es
auftritt voll wird ist ungewiss
40 Tickets wurden im Vorhinein verkauft
doch es ist unwahrscheinlich dass die
Leute alle kommen die no show Raid ist
bei kleinen Konzerten zuletzt hoch viele
haben den Termin vergessen das Ticket
verloren werden nicht kommen lasse auf
deswegen auf spontane Gäste
da wo wir als Künstler jetzt Geld
verdienen das sind tatsächlich bei
Konzerte weil Streaming ist sowieso sehr
sehr wenig Geld und von daher ist es
sehr wichtig dass wir diese
Live-Konzerte spielen können und das
auch Leute kommen wenn kaum jemand kommt
macht das ebenso den Veranstaltungsorten
zu schaffen sie sind darauf angewiesen
an der Bar Geld zu verdienen die
Konsequenz lasse hat wie viele andere
kleine Bands Konzerte absagen müssen
eine schmerzhafte Entscheidung wenn ich
und meine burkerins dafür entschieden
haben
wir schon viel Geld investiert ich habe
also auf der businessebene er auch eine
ganze Album gemacht das kostet viel Geld
ich habe Promotion gemacht das kostet
viel Geld
und dann ist es natürlich keine schöne
Sache zu wissen dass das diese Musik
wird jetzt nicht live gespielt und ich
werde auf keinen Fall da irgendwie in
diese Städte Geld verdienen oder
albumsverkaufen auch im vizemann einer
Konzert location in Stuttgart ist
zuletzt einiges ausgefallen oft
kurzfristig mit Blick auf das früher ist
die Crew optimistischer sie überbrücken
die ruhigen Monate mit Testläufen für
eine neue Party ein Problem aber macht
sorgen
also wir haben natürlich deutlich mehr
kosten im letzten Jahres bekommen auch
was Dienstleister angeht natürlich und
wir sind halt versuchen dass das ein
Einklang bringen das Leute noch ganz zu
uns kommen zur Veranstaltungen aber
nicht zu viel zahlen müssen also es ist
gerade nicht einfach die
Preiskalkulation zu gestalten
Inflation und hohe Energiepreise
belasten den Betrieb zusätzlich zu den
Folgen der corona-einschränkungen
Betriebsleiterin Hanna jap ist
einerseits froh dass das Team wieder
beisammen ist andererseits
als Betrieb ist es nach wie vor einfach
mega schwierig es ist einfach so ein
bisschen so eine Planbarkeit
reingekommen dass wir noch nicht wieder
vorher war es halt relativ verlässlich
wie das Jahr so läuft und das ist noch
nicht wieder da und das ist einfach
irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdiges
Gefühl dass man immer noch in so eine
unwerkbarkeit irgendwie rein arbeitet
und beim Personal besser planen zu
können hat der Betrieb mehr
Technikerinnen und Techniker fest
angestellt statt beim Personal zu kürzen
man will unabhängiger von Dienstleister
Preisen sein um dem Team mehr Sicherheit
zu bieten viele waren wegen der Pandemie
in Kurzarbeit kamen teilweise schwer
über die Runden wechselten
zurück ins Merlin hier kann lasse
spielen egal wie viele Menschen zu
seinem Konzert kommen egal ob sich damit
Geld verdienen lässt getragen wird die
Location von einem Verein diese Art von
Gelassenheit gibt schon an unserer
Förderung die wir auch als Auftrag sehen
des dann durchzuziehen und Künstler auf
unsere Bühne dem unsere Bühne zu bieten
wir sagen von uns aus immer kommt her
ihr dürft spielen und es uns ist es
erstmal in dem Moment wichtiger dass die
Künstler kommen und Platz haben zum
Spielen und das Konzerte stattfinden
hier arbeiten Ehrenamtler an der Kasse
und hinter der Bar ohne sie während die
Kleinen Konzerte nicht finanzierbar
der spontan zulasses Konzert kommt Zeit
20 €. das machen an diesem Abend vier
Leute
falls reingeguckt ihn gedacht heute
Abend muss ich hin und dann wollte ich
noch jemanden mitnehmen und so hat sich
das gegeben man ist Single man geht
gerne raus man erlebt ein bisschen was
man lebt gern vor allem nach den letzten
Jahren
hier geht es heute Abend um die Musik
nicht um das Geld und trotzdem kurz
bevor es losgeht ist Trummer Martin
etwas frustriert
ja es ist ein bisschen so wie man
irgendwie Wellensurfen geht und die
Wellen sind halt einfach zu klein na so
ist es halt immer so müssen wir also es
ist irgendjemand so als müsste man seine
eigene das muss man handeln während man
eigentlich während man gerade noch
surfen geht
[Musik]
bei kommerziellen Kulturstätten wie dem
vizemann nagen die steigenden Preise
weiter an der Substanz helfen soll nun
der Energie vor Kultur die
Bundesregierung stellt bis zu 1
Milliarde Euro bereit die soll verwendet
werden um Kulturangebote wie
beispielsweise Kinos Konzerte oder
Museen zu erhalten und Hanna jap ist
hofft dass der vor zukünftig hilft hohe
Energiepreise zu bewältigen auch wenn
manche Liebe ohne Staatshilfen
zurechtkommen würden zum Beispiel auch
Leute die diesen Energie vor jetzt sehr
kritisch sehen weil die halt sagen hey
es wurde genug gefördert jetzt muss
müssen die Betriebe das auch mal wieder
alleine schaffen und den Ansatz verstehe
ich nur also finde ich schwierig
manchmal wünsche ich mir fast auch dass
man sagen wird okay dann fördert es
nicht und seht was passiert weil dann
wäre eben die Folge das halt ganz viel
einfach zusammenbrechen würde
es sei frustrierend ein weiteres Jahr
immer erstmal ans Überleben denken zu
müssen statt in neue Projekte
investieren zu können in der
Veranstaltungsbranche Arbeiten 1,5
Millionen Menschen für die fordert der
Bund der Veranstalter weitere Hilfen und
warnt ein Worst Case-Szenario ist das
nur noch die Dinge veranstaltet werden
die man sicher auch finanzieren kann die
auf tragfähigen wirtschaftlichen Beinen
stehen das wird zu einem Mainstream
führen in dem Kulturleben und es wird
das Kulturleben auch kleiner und ärmer
machen
im Berlin hat lasse matthesen sein
Konzert gespielt
ich weiß nicht wie viele da waren dass
die man von oben eigentlich nicht nee
aber das hört sich gut angekommen
knapp 40 Leute waren heute da und so
wird 2023 zeigen ob sich die Branche
trotz aller Krisen tatsächlich
aufrappeln kann